[Music]
he's in my new room yeah he's been
maneuver
[Music]
you need to go no no I'm staying right
here with you
[Music]
whoa what'd you run a right 20 right
page
[Music]
okay straight on this bowl
hey hey listen you hear me you treat
somebody on the phone so when I
checked it up I'm talking to somebody
you got that you stay on their phone yes
murder tritrippy I want you to go with
God we're doing okay all right just keep
the right 15 15 that's Jesse left 15
runners
[Music]
20 left 20 and don't leave this phone
what do you want what do you like that
they're firing into steering-gear room
they're firing into the steering gear
room everybody's okay brothers left 10
we got another one out here
[Music]
yeah I know but look we got this one we
got one out here we got to go wait you
mix-ups
yeah
same problem I had